- Here we go, Gary, I'm
sending you over sides
for an audition,
it's a big role.
It's a Sundance type Indie
film, shooting in four weeks.
- Oh my God, yes,
yes, this is it!
- Okay the only thing is you
have to do a British accent,
can you do that or?
- I think I can bloody do it!
- Okay great, sending
you over the sides now.
Talk to you later.
- Amazing, I love
you so much Amy!
This is it, this is it!
Oh my God, where's the
Julie, where's the Julie?
(heavy bass, hip hop music)
You sit here, after mum
died in front of you.
You sit here like a piece of
shit from the fucking gutter.
Mum loved you, she
treated you like a son,
which you most
certainly were not.
So I'll say this to you
once, and only once,
before you rot in prison.
You go to bloody fucking hell!
How was it?
- Wow, that's the 47th
time I've seen it,
it keeps getting better.
Dude, Daniel Day Lewis
could suck your dick.
- Yeah, man, I really feel
like this is my Oscar moment.
You know what I mean?
If I get nominated, I'm
going to thank you first,
obviously, Amy, then
everybody in Iowa,
then Leo and Streep,
you know what I mean?
They're gonna be
like who is this guy,
we gotta work with him
and Spielberg's like,
I got it, I'll direct it.
- The Academy Awards, I'm
gonna be so high on Molly.
I'm gonna make out
with Morgan Freeman.
- He will not like that.
- Ah, then Michael Kane, yeah.
(hip hop music)
- I just want to
say thanks, man.
You were there from day
one, part of this journey,
into a realm where I don't
know where I'm even going.
- Okay don't go full
Gandalph on me yet,
save it for the room.
- You're a true Julie.
- Got a lot of
competition in here.
- These guys are a
bunch of dirty lollies.
Ah, Gregorn, man, knack it out,
what time was your flight?
- What's that?
- From London, I just
flew in, I'm so tired.
Had a couple pints on the
plane but I'll be alright.
- Oh, welcome, I'm from LA.
- Man this project,
right, you read it?
Fire, pure fire!
Everyone's prattlin about
in the museums in London,
just prattling away
on the streets.
You know it was at the
pub's prattling away,
it's gonna be good.
- Really, such a small movie?
- Small movie, small
attitude, that's what that is.
- So this is Gary
Scalzo, Hi Gary.
- Hey.
- We got so lucky today, we
have our director here so.
- What, I didn't know
he was going to be here.
- Just came from a Tarantino
set this morning so.
- Tarantino, yeah
that guy's sick man.
- Yeah, we're old
friends, collaborators.
He'll definitely see this
so it's good for you.
- He's gonna see it?
Great.
- So do you have any questions?
- About what?
Questions?
- About the script?
- No, should I have?
I didn't prepare questions,
I didn't know you'd be here
so it's like, you
know, I didn't,
questions for Tarantino?
- No just wanted to know
if you had any thoughts
about the character, you know.
- You don't have to.
- Quentin punched the script up.
- I thought the script was
funny, it made me laugh.
- Which part made you laugh?
- The part with the cat
when he jumps on the table.
- The cat jumps out the window.
- The cat commits suicide.
- Yeah the cat dies.
- Yeah and then the son
finds the mother's dead body.
- Yeah the cat jumps over
the mother's dead body
and I just thought it was funny.
I grew up with cats.
- Well let's get started.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whenever you're ready.
- Okay, cool.
What are you doing
here mate at the pub?
Why are you here?
You know, mom's dead.
- You know, let's do
the British accent.
- Oh yeah, right,
yeah of course.
- Hello!
Was that too big?
Let me do it again, let me try,
let me try it one more time.
Let me try it again.
(clears throat)
Hello poppet!
Are you nervous about
going down to the barbie?
- Okay, we're good.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- No you go to bloody hell.
You go to bloody hell.
- Very interesting take, Gary,
very interesting, thank you.
- Thank you.
- You go to bloody hell.
- I thought we had our last one.
- Hey, how'd it go mate?
- Did you sign in?
- Oh no, I'm just with Gary.
- Well you have the accent down,
there's nobody left, wanna try?
- Uh, no, I'm good, I think
actors are fucking stupid.
Oh, except for Gary.
- I do like that
attitude, come on in.
You have a good look.
- I thought we were
gonna get cereal.
- Oh yeah, after, after.
She's hot.
(hip hop beat)
- Ello, ello.
Fuck.
Bloody shit.
- Hahahaha y'all a
bunch of bloody wankers,
the whole lot of ya, fuck
you this movie sucks.
- Fuck Eric, that was great,
we're gonna follow up with Amy.
- Ciao, muah muah.
- Dude, Amy's not your manager.
- Whatever dude, who cares,
let's go get some cereal.
(hip hop music)
- So they said you were a
tad green and a little tight
and a bit loud.
- But he was nailing it at home.
- Yeah, Rick saw it, I
had it down dude, right?
Yeah, but the only
thing that threw me was,
I didn't know the director
was gonna be there,
he just surprised
me, you know, I mean,
that's not cool, I
mean, I was thrown off.
- Okay, well you're gonna
have to get used to that
if you want to book a job.
- But Rick, they were
very intrigued by you.
Okay, I know you don't
want to be an actor,
but I've gotten
such great feedback.
Everyone, the casting,
producers, director,
the photographer Todd.
I'd like to submit
you for auditions.
- Okay, as long as it works
around my video game schedule.
And weed.
- We can do that.
- And coke, let's
not leave that out.
- Sometimes.
- And Molly and meth, I mean,
there's a myriad of drugs
that Rick does.
But also do you think
that there's room for him
on our client list because
we're all going out,
you know, we're doing our
thing kind of in a groove.
Does Rick, I hope he
does, but does he fit in?
- No, it's fine,
I can make space.
- And you're not gonna go
in for the same stuff, okay?
He'll be the leading man.
- Right and I'm like a
second leading man, right?
- Weird friend,
awkward guy at the bar.
- Oh, hey if I book something
I can pay for my own cereal.
- Oh that's true.
- Oh, dude let me
post this shit.
- What?
(camera click)
(heavy bass music)